welcome to this film as requested I'll
do another video on one of my over the
board games I'm sorry yeah in fact I
played this game just today and I'm
still tired from the game so please bear
with me but isn't a super long video ok
let's start it was played in the the
German league here for German team and
my opponent isn't a German international
master with rating about to 360 so
someone will play in his 50s but that's
the very solid so let's see what happens
I opened Knight f3 no ID f6 g3 yeah
often play that I have some ideas in
various lines prepared you play d5
though and it went into some sort of
london system reversed yeah this is
often called yeah the last car set up
against the red team it's basically a
london system reverse as mentioned yeah
here why test a couple of options for
example what can play the the classic
ready move b3 with there should be 2 d 3
and so on this is the super solid way to
play white can also play move like d3
attending these kind of maneuvers this
is also good what I played is also
possibility C takes d5 and this has some
some concrete ideas if black would
recapture with the C pawn then Queen b3
is a bit of a nuisance as p7 is hanging
and like needs to spend a move with his
Queen and if he plays will be 6 I have
various ideas that can take on b6
damaging his pawn structure I can play
d3
and the Bishop III this would damage my
bone structure but this is something the
others differently a file actually would
give me some player let's just put
something on the go to show what I mean
now ninety-four is an idea and I have
somewhat techie I'm a seven this is some
unknown line which is somewhat better
for white however you get recaptured
with the e pawn which is probably more
logical anyway now I play d3 there
should be seven Queen b3 this is all
pretty normal
the Queen again attacking this pawn so
black plays Queen b6 to protect us and I
drop back to see - yeah this might look
like loss of time at first in fact this
isn't the case the Queen wants to go to
C - anyway because it wants to prepare
this before move so white will play
Knight c3 and he form and the idea is
that the Queen will be six sometimes
worse then on d8 as white we would Tempe
with Bishop e3 sometimes Knight c3 to a
form so I sort of gifted him the move
Queen b6 but very often the Queen are
only M gets a kicked again on the six
and therefore this is a quite useful
move towards Earth's queen bee three
castles Knight c3 ninety seven ninety
four so this is in essence the idea that
white was introducing with the capture
on g5 why he's got extra pawn in the
center and he advances on the center
pole so a black plays here and I grabbed
the bishop pair black has no choice he
needs to take
one in three if he would would actually
go to age five there are some at least
this idea an ith force also also
interesting but G form probably leads to
a good position I'll get this
Bishop I have a tempo in in yeah some
sorry Sophia then I can that I can use
so I grab the bishops and have extra
form in the center and on the kingside
so in the game we took I think this is
also better but now it's clear that
white should enjoy a slight advantage
I've got the two bishops and the extra
center corners mentioned and
possibilities on the kingside in fact
him the game it worked out very nicely
he played the Moose Rock ft8 now I don't
really like that I think he probably
should take and play something like Ruby
eight rope yet and rook 88 doctor it's
um it's not not easy to play this
position anyway I think white is some
slightly better anyway yeah I dropped
back to prepare they have forms of
course not possible at the moment you to
the pin but I need to move the bishop
first to think about this move at all
and now we took on e4 and this is really
a concession maybe like could could try
other things I'm not sure
move like that maybe yeah but what white
should be better I may be slightly
biased I really like this kind of
structure as white got the two bishops
you've got mobile majority here and
black really doesn't have much play it's
clear that after this I'm pretty
distinctly better because this oops
officially three will come with the
tempo it's four against three yet and
this this prongs are ready to go
he now played this with which also is
rather accommodating I'd like to get
into the pin of course and so he loses
another move with the Queen needs to get
out of the pin move like this simply get
sauntered with him and be fun it's also
just nothing yet yeah I already have a
huge choice I can play various good
moves up later okay anyone here also f4
was good or even rook c1 was an idea
with this kind of idea will not be five
depending on the circumstances it's a
rather ugly for black really but Brooke
eighty-one is certainly alright yeah he
just took and played repudiate so very
simple approach just exchanging but this
leads to to a great position for white
took on d8 Queen takes he needed to
otherwise c5 would hang and now he
fought and therefore so a great position
advancing the pawns and gain more space
of course he also could have gone to d7
here it's pretty similar here white also
has a key advantage to bishops and this
majority of the system
this is just very uncomfortable for
black yeah he played 98 f4
yeah probably one idea of this was the
following move which is also simply bad
Queen d3 this I was really shocked to
and this was play because it's it's
really rather obviously bad Queen ever
to just drop the Queen to the side and
attack the knight and what is this queen
doing except getting kicked away um in
fact he played um 96 which probably M is
the only move
yeah and here's some the first critical
position of the game where I made them
you know rather human move against our
play King to h2 in fact I can just take
yourselves 96 in fact I can just take a
six and a seven
of course I solved this move but I
wasn't so sure if he plays this
admittedly very ugly move c5 which opens
up everything here I wasn't 100% sure if
this is really a really winning this not
this Bishop on a7 is some a bit stranded
it cannot return easily it seems that
this kind of move from seems to win who
in d8 and Queen f3 this is what the
computer wants to play simply attacking
b7 and yeah the the computer senses this
is winning probably he is right this is
pure calculation kind of position you
know but I couldn't couldn't do this I
wanted to apply to as mentioned King
edge tree I wanted to keep control of
the position and simply win the tempo on
the Queen next I mean this is still a
very clear advantage but Bishop a7 was
probably better still not a very you
move I guess at least them fearful for
me
he played a six that secured the pole
and now f5 this was my idea
yeah here I've got the multiple
possibilities everything's creepy
advantage it's hard to tell what's
really the best I played night 2 to e
form which had two ideas one idea was to
play f6 and the other was to play Bishop
to c5 I only changed my plans afterwards
this was also a good idea
and white simply is simply better
something like this it's just yeah those
two pieces are just are just great look
at this piece so white is some is
clearly betim 94 wasn't bad though like
95 is better here I'm here to changed my
mind
my original idea was to play in this
position Bishop to c5 the idea was that
black can hardly a wire to this trade so
if you look at this position I have an
excellent night on c5 but when I looked
at this a bit deeper I didn't really see
how to how to make big progress here in
fact I have a very strong move but I
didn't see this here the move I needed
to see him in my calculation was the
Knight to d7 and this is really strong
really we'd move if you look at it it's
crystal clear but still I didn't till
consider this at all
the idea is quincy 5 which would
threaten mate and therefore basically am
yeah
forces the Queen exchange and and this
kind of endgame is simply winning
because of not on c5 it takes b7 and
this cannot be protected I also have the
far better bishops than than those lame
Knights so this is just just a winning
position for example a5 quincy 5 - just
put it on the board
e - exchange yeah and now this pawn is
the problem like play something like
this and i can proceed in this fashion
and black is black is terrible here you
can continue if you want them no King
comes yeah terrible position but I then
was attracted by something else I played
this move with the ID f6 and unless they
mated that black can play f6 now himself
which in fact he didn't do he should do
this f6 is pretty ok for black I can and
I can take and let's say something like
this it's still better for y2 to do due
to the bishops but it's um it's probably
playable for lucky so you've got this
Lex got this strong point now on d5 this
is of course a disadvantage shown of the
c5 booth so um f6 was a threat and he
didn't address this he just played this
move and now I won't have six it's not
clear that this was really the best move
maybe a move like a three or still
Bishop c5 was better I was attracted by
this Knight to g5 it looks very strong
attacking and we should be for coming
but black can't save himself what he
only has got one move which he didn't
play black needs to play now Queen g6
and my intention was h4 h6 we should be
for Queen h5 and then I thought all
right here here here there must be
something this is the kind of
calculation that sometimes just leads to
disaster in fact white doesn't have have
a great continuation here
funny enough I mean it looks terrible
for black but probably I need to settle
with this in my calculation I always
thought I can if everything else fails I
can always repeat moves right so I'm
okay but it just didn't happen in fact
in the game after after 95 you played
Bishop h6 and this loses instantly the
first move I made was correct we should
be for the obvious roof also Queen D
once on Bishop
h7 check king of a yeah and here I made
the first mistake really up to this
point I think it was rather decent
rather decent game by by me but here
made a mistake
I simply overlooked him rather rather
simple idea but I played this move but
better is Bishop to c2 the problem is
what should like do now I thought he
might retreat to h5 let's say here and
then the problem is the following I only
thought about Bishop c5 check and this
infect isn't so clear look at this it
looks terrible but there is no clear win
no completely clear when the Queen
covers f7 and it's not clear this is
also hanging the problem is I don't I
don't need to do two to play this check
I have another move and this move is the
the winning move I didn't consider this
at all I mean this is really bad that I
didn't didn't do consider the problem is
whatever black plays the King move
obviously I have g4 the queen is trapped
I didn't think about this idea at all
you know he simply has no way to to save
the Queen now he can give the desperado
cheque which I can just take and then
I'm piece up for nothing
yeah I simply overlooked Knight h7 this
idea this is why I didn't play Bishop c2
I played this check first King e8 gypsy
- yeah now there's there's no check of
course but okay white is still yeah much
better
94 I got this extra pawn now I've got 96
coming but like with 96 I mean he's
still playing he's not resigning yet and
the other line are just just one
outright so I was already slightly
annoyed yeah at my own failure because I
felt I really felt that the game should
have been over already so I gave this
check he played King D 7 which in fact
is a mistake but it was difficult we
both didn't have much time note that the
time see a complete nonsense and on the
other clocks it was some played with
them or to our time control with
increment but - I'm sorry I'm about to
to our tampered from King f8 was better
but this is also a move that it's hard
to hard to see because he was simply
wooden you walk into into this oops
- this discovery why does much better
still but this this is better than the
game he went here and now I didn't have
much time on the clock as I said and I
simply overlooked and
something here in fact I made a mistake
will not be seven I could win with
Bishop f5 I didn't really calculate at
this point I just I just made a move and
I took on b7 them and this is stronger
the ideas amongst others G for checking
this Queen and if it moves then I can
probably take f7 with a knight this is
one one at the end
okay simply this Bishop into the light
so it protects c5 in a way this is this
is winning there are even some some nice
tricks here let's say b6 we should
reform queen here otherwise I'll take it
and then this move yeah bit of a
computer line why does winning totally
here so it's not even so difficult once
you see indeed the first moves yeah I
just took took here and thought alright
okay this is two points I must I must
win now somehow and then you played this
move and and it was really am really
uncool that this was happening and now
I'm in trouble all these pieces are
somewhat loose and I was glad to have
this move which with which secures yeah
still some some play some sets him some
problems let's say the problem is what
should I do if I if I just move the
knight away you can take here here like
we need to and it's a perpetual I cannot
escape this just a shame and yeah what
what should I play the knight is hanging
and everything sir
just just bad
I found Bishop f5 which is the move that
sets the most problems and yeah here
black can draw outright but he didn't
see it I mean we both didn't have much
time we're close to town control played
this which is a mistake
but it was very difficult to see him he
actually could take here which I
absolutely also rejected outright but it
is in fact playable can take here now
seven this is what I saw and I thought
okay I'm promoting and probably win the
game but black has nine f6 and this is
what we both overlooked and this is
strong it threatens some Knight to g4
the pawn is hanging also so why it
basically doesn't have any other move
than taking and then black can simply
take here if I now choose to grab the
the bishop then he's got a perpetual and
in fact I cannot avoid getting getting
perpetual to him that's simply a draw
Knight f6 is very strong with both on
didn't see this at all he decided to at
the end play this move which is also
interesting probably I'm not sure I
didn't see this line out so it this this
Knight f6 line I mean we both missed it
but this if you look at this it is
obvious that black has some play for the
pawns
there should be three years keys yeah
securing this Queen I took on a six of
course King b6 and queen f1 and now I
can barely cover both pieces and they're
both in a way stranded they're not
protected by any pawn and especially the
night on a six is really a problem piece
it can go - yeah b8 that the only
or East where I'm sorry I'm really tired
of this game and the only square
basically and yeah
he's got pretty well coordinated pieces
so I wasn't sure he at all about this
position yeah it's it seems that white
is still somewhat better but it's a
really difficult to play in fact we both
made some more mistakes yeah he played
Queen f5 I Queen g5 which is probably
alright getting a queen on the dark
square and attacking here probably
intending to take here yeah I played
Knight to b8 yeah and this is maybe not
the best move but I think this is really
beyond human understanding what you
should do here because I mean maybe if
you're a super strong calculator which
I'm not then you can maybe play another
way the computer wants to play this and
gives white rather distinct advantage I
mean I saw this move obviously but I
wasn't clear I wasn't sure at all how do
I get this Knight back into play I mean
this is just stranded here I always need
to use the piece to to keep it even and
where do I go I thought you came to play
something like this and how do I make
progress now he will get this pawn and
okay it's two pawns I know but how do I
make progress without the night I simply
I simply didn't see any any direct
concept the computer wants to play stuff
like this the idea being to play reform
and combining all kinds of tactical
ideas this for example yeah it's um it's
interesting probably is this is better I
mean the computers usually right in
these positions but it's not it's not
not easy at all
a possible line that I can show is after
this will rip you three Queeny five and
before this is also an idea but this is
for example a line that the computer
gives us winning for white which I'm not
sure at all so let's say this and
computers things that this kind of oops
this kind of line should win this the
computer senses is winning for white
which I am yeah absolutely not sure
about it's just one pawn he gives this
as one point two and I'm not sure this
Bishop is always controlling h8 and like
Scott a C pawn also it's not clear I
mean white is better sure but if you're
winning it's it's not clear to me so um
yeah all right I played this move the
idea being to get the Knight to d7 it's
it looks weird but I thought from d7 it
at least protect this pawn and maybe at
one day I can get to e5 yeah he played
King um came back attacking the knight
and I went to d7 as as mentioned and
yeah here black probably could draw the
game I said probably because it's really
difficult
he played Bishop to a7 getting this
Bishop out of the way so to say I
thought this was better and in fact the
computer guru is one of the very few
instances in the game where the computer
agrees with my move my assessment let's
say I think this is better really um a
possible line which is not easy at all
to play is this
on let's say an alternative is h4 just
to show it then you give the check just
and this is similar to the game actually
and the draw look at the game at you
you'll understand why this is a drawn so
the idea could be this one but this is
also very very tricky I mean look at
this move at first you think all right
and it's friends made probably you need
to exchange and now we've got an issue
with this bishop but the computer just
wants to play the funny move Bishop e6
which you all need to see before and
otherwise you probably worse even and
this completely insane line is better
full-height it looks completely
completely ridiculous but it seems to be
better for white he needs to now take
care and why to take cm this this in
fact after f7 loses the point being that
I threatened this and f8 and this is
also not better sort of a fork
threatening f8 Queen and taking the the
bishop yeah white is winning yeah that
this is in fact the land is that is
close to winning but it's super
difficult I mean really difficult and
black on after this move doesn't need to
play Queen e3 is just a sample line I
think so the thing this is better than
then the game probably he went to a 7
and yeah now it's my turn
and
probably I had a better move now a plain
age form it might be alright but the
idea of connected with it was wrong
there are alternatives here in fact the
computer gives we have this stuff like
Bishop b6 which I didn't really consider
and it's probably also not not too clear
and an idea though was 95 the idea is
that after this Queen a6 is winning c6
is the problem this move here but he
doesn't need to play this he this is the
problem what I didn't see here was that
after this I thought this wasn't too
great because there's this I mean it is
this this and now I can I can take and
this is some huge advantage for white
I simply underestimated this position so
maybe 95 was better the computer is also
not completely sure probably need deep
analysis in fact after after this here
on black can even go here
and that continues it's very tricky
still I mean it looks ridiculous reports
but like has all kinds of kinds of
tricks iam well ok
I played aged form so he gave this
cheque and now I'm I probably must play
queen g2 I played this the thing is it
symbolized before I saw this but what I
didn't see is that in this position
after this move I have actually King he
formed
and now I'm the only one with winning
chances because the following line is
some is forced really it takes takes
here here H five yeah the pawns are
dangerous obviously and this is probably
the line funny I don't have a check so
he will he will get a queen and now I
can I can play here and here I still
have some some chances to win the game
with the two advanced pawns black of
course has chances 2-2 draw with with
headshots yeah no question but this is a
risk-free way to try to win the game of
course this is a rather deep variation
but yeah twinsies - this was Queen G -
probably better because this in fact is
a draw and he starts with the right move
replaces a bishop f - and this is good
attacking g3 this is an idea and also
this is an idea and here white can
easily lose the game for example if you
play 95 now then Queen e3 just wins
because yeah this move yeah we'll get
you hope that you toast it quickly he
got like some blacks active so this is
not not so easy
I played Quincy for which yeah it's
alright but should lead to draw really
funny enough and he needed to play in
order to to get this drawn out he needed
to play when you
with this idea and in fact there's
nothing I can do to to avoid the draw he
simply has a ton of checks I can play
some moves that actually loose let's say
here this move and and I'm done can can
get ugly really quickly here for let's
say Queen a6 and Queen a3 is almost made
but this isn't me yeah yeah you can
easily even even lose the game I mean it
was really annoyed that this was on the
board considering how easy am the win
was some time ago yeah but what draws
actually I think will be three year
service is one of the draws
overprotecting g3 and - this kind of
stuff is a perpetual yeah this would
have drawn queenie one he played this
and this is a yeah the big mistake which
is answered by another mistake I played
Queen g4 and I thought before that this
is I know they only move really just
covering g3 in fact I could play here
and this is much stronger really hard to
understand why I didn't see this move I
mean I was a bit tired but still the
ideas just checkmate here so black must
exchange I simply didn't consider
covering g3 from the side just a
geometrical problem somehow yeah black
must exchange now and this this endgame
yeah it's three pawns black has some
ideas due to the opposite colored
bishops but yeah
I should have very good winning chances
and I must play that nevertheless
whatever the chances are if it's winning
on just a cleared watch I must play this
because the alternative
Quinn G could you falsify what I played
actually now black can draw again but
this is not so easy if you made a
mistake again II played this one this in
fact draws with this idea but this is
very surprising this I didn't also see
during the game and again white has
nothing that you can do to avoid this
let's say here yeah black get some
whoops like this one sorry of course of
the check here F 1 and again a check
yeah the king is simply simply M
impossible to to get out there it is a
perpetual what can you do Bishop you won
but he played this and now after Bishop
before I'm finally and completely
winning again yeah I'm covering this
kiito's critical square cm and simply
threaten to take it and 95 this is too
much not quite sure what he what he
overlooked with this I mean you can
overlook maybe Bishop G 1 but I'm not
sure why played this because we should
be false really relatively easy to see
but yeah it was some game full of
mistakes also maybe due to the fact that
the match was also rather tight I don't
know
he played Bishop a5 now and in fact
black has no move he emits it's just
over it took and before I'd like said
like this doesn't have any counter play
now played here
and him yeah white is more than one way
to win I played this attacking d5 and
after deform this move this this blocks
the pawn and of course threatens Queen
d7 played here and yeah here gave this
check of course I thought this would
would win rather easily taking here but
then then I noticed one line let's have
a look so check him and he I first
thought okay this and this and it's and
I'm winning because this it's really
easy but then he has taught this and
after I saw this line which is a
perpetual again I thought alright maybe
this isn't so clear if I take I just
dropped back black has no move yeah
maybe needed to go back and then Knight
c4 I mean this this is good enough just
winning the bishop let's play this
that's if I now resigns because after d2
I can I can simply take it Queen takes
Queen f4 and yeah the Sun this I'll win
even on a bad day like today yeah again
with lots of mistakes by both sides but
this is also again sign of the times
that the computer points out all those
mistakes instantaneously and it isn't so
easy to play over the bots it's it's
really it's not a correspondents game
you cannot ask a computer and you can
miss calculate on on every move and in
fact we both did so in the game on more
than one occasion the only thing that
that is really bad to think umm I should
have made this night h7 check this
wasn't was it too difficult to see
really this winning line around here
when I played this check and Bishop c2
and oops I cannot make arrows Bishop c2
and edge terminals winning rather rather
easily yeah
despite the mistake some help you
enjoyed the game I think it was it was
it was still interesting from a
technical point of view and also I was
some pretty interesting this kind of
position because at first you think
three pawns yeah what was win easily but
it isn't easy at all try to analyze this
for yourself with the computer and
you'll find that Lex counter play is
really really a problem yeah thanks for
watching and I'll be back soon with new
stuff